estamos trabajando con un problema de
conversión de monedas y tenemos este
ejercicio que dice david está de
vacaciones en dinamarca y quiere
gastarse 35 pesos en una nueva chamarra
la chamarra que le gusta cuesta 205
coronas danesas un peso puede ser
convertido en 6 coronas danesas y dice
david tendrá tenemos aquí un cuadrito
donde pondremos el resultado de el total
de coronas danesas que tendrá david si
convierte sus 35 pesos ahora la pregunta
es si tiene suficiente dinero para
comprar la chamarra entonces bueno david
tiene 35 pesos y cada peso puede ser
convertido en 6 coronas danesas entonces
multiplicamos 35 por 6 que es lo mismo
que multiplicar cuánto es esto 30 por 6
eso es igual a 180 más 5 por 6 que es 30
entonces
180 30 es igual a 210 210 coronas
danesas es el total de de del dinero que
tendrá ahora david ahora tiene
suficiente dinero para comprar la
chamarra claro porque tiene 210 y la
chamarra solo cuesta 205 entonces la
respuesta es si david tiene suficiente
para comprar la chamarra
comprobando respuesta y estamos en lo
correcto